and your loved ones well and for too
many families that
right now are on pins and needles that
have somebody who you love who is sick
because of covet 19
or who's suffering through this season
want you to know you're not alone that
we are one city together
arm in arm marching through this thick
fog of covet 19 and i assure you that
there are better days
ahead there are things that are still
happening each and every day
here people who are doing the essential
work
showing up in our grocery stores
firefighters
some from the city of los angeles
helping our brothers and sisters on the
fire line
in the bonfire in orange county life
hasn't stopped it's just been changed
in this toughest of years and so i
wanted to
share with you tonight a couple of
things about where we're at right now
and to share with you the news we got
from the state
so often in this crisis it can be so
confusing
orders come down from the state from our
county
we're not sure what they mean when they
come into effect
oftentimes with no notice our life just
changes like that
what we can and can't do what we're
supposed to
and not supposed to do and so each of
these evening briefings i try to give
you
the hard truths but also explain what's
going on
and tonight i'd like to do that governor
newsome announced
yesterday a new framework for regional
stay-at-home orders
throughout the state of california and i
know how confusing can be
to track these changes but there's one
simple truth that we know we've learned
how to contain this virus we just have
to do it
the simple truth that we know zikovit-19
rapidly spreads and it rapidly spreads
as a result of our own behavior
but we also know that we can slow that
spread by wearing a mask
by washing our hands by keeping our
distance
by not traveling by cancelling our plans
by empowering ourselves to defeat this
enemy
and to make sure that we save the lives
of those that we love
it's that simple we are the ones who
avert the disaster
it's how we will protect our workers and
our families make sure that a nurse can
show up
for his next shift make sure that
somebody
who's stocking the shelves so that we
can eat doesn't get sick at the end of
the day
today the numbers were stark
again and record setting in a bad way
eight thousand eight hundred and sixty
cases
a number i can hardly believe just a few
weeks ago it would have been
unimaginable
and we're on the verge of ten thousand
cases daily
with the numbers that we're seeing this
week
getting this virus under control is
mission
critical mission critical for los
angeles and i know that we can do this
when our public health officials give us
guidance they're working on the same
basic equation
california has more virus cases now than
at any point
in this pandemic and we will soon have
more cases
than we have available hospital beds we
are perilously close to running out
of intensive care unit or icu beds
so let's get to what the state announced
nothing has changed for la
yet but what they did announce is that
los angeles is part of a region
that goes from as far north as san luis
vispo and inyo counties all the way down
to the mexican border
and that when the icu beds that are in
southern california
are 85 percent filled it will trigger
new closures now here in los angeles
most of those things
are already closed by the county orders
that we had so we won't see a lot change
but if and when that day comes and by
the way projections show it could come
as early as this weekend
or early next week when 85 percent of
southern california's icu beds are
filled
the state has now mandated that a few
other things close and let me run you
through those so you can know what to
anticipate know what you're still
allowed to do and be ready for when it
comes
first personal care whether it's nail
salons
getting a haircut at the barber or
beauty salon those will close
as will family entertainment centers and
cultural destinations from zoos
to aquariums and museums to places like
batting cages
and mini golf those places will close
and those right now are currently open
but to be clear
they are open the state has not mandated
that they close yet
it's only when 85 percent of the icu
beds
are filled second hotels are now
not for tourism they're essential stays
only
and third there is also a reduction
in our essential businesses from 35
capacity to 20
capacity when we hit that threshold that
will mean
that people will be paced into our
supermarkets our essential
places like pharmacies when that day
comes so to summarize
what did the state do it said when the
southern california region
has 85 percent of its icu beds filled
there will be some additional closures
most of those closures already have
occurred here in los angeles but what
will change
is that you can no longer go to personal
care you can no longer go to family
entertainment cultural destinations
and those essential businesses that are
allowed to have 35 percent will go to 20
capacity simple as that
we had more cases this last week than we
had in the entire
month of october and each day we're
seeing more people in the hospital and
our icu beds
for this reason as i mentioned we're
likely to pass that threshold that the
state has mandated
um in the next few days of 85 percent
filled
when they go into effect the state's
closures apply to everybody by the way
even though los angeles county
has already begun and started those
closures before it will now wash over
all of the southern california region
those counties imperial inyo los angeles
mono
orange riverside san bernadino san diego
san luis bispo
santa barbara and ventura will go
together
and the state's planned closures and
restrictions are very similar to what's
already in place
so not a lot will change here
campgrounds also will remain open but
overnight stays will not be permitted
no one wants to be in these positions no
one wants to see these things close
those decisions are painful for all of
us and i know so many of you write to me
saying why is the city doing this
well i support our public health
professionals and i have since the
beginning of this crisis
remember cities can't open up whether
it's los angeles
pomona santa clarita or long beach we
can't open up
more than what the county allows or the
state allows
we are together on these things to make
sure
that there isn't a variation from one
city to the next
nor do we have those authorities except
in pasadena and long beach which have
their own health departments
so to review the simple truths are stay
home
whenever you can don't share your air
don't gather with others outside your
household in this critical period
and just be smart and stay apart
this is a painful season to go through
those things we all want to be together
it's the holidays
this is a time when we get to take a
pause usually and be with our loved ones
and our family members
but know that the act of love is to not
be with them is to not go outside of our
household to keep our friends
from being part of this spread and yes
some of them from losing their lives
to remind people outdoor recreation is
very much still
open and i encourage people in this
tough
time you remember the beginning of this
take care of your mental health your
spiritual health
whether it's in prayer whether it's in
being able to go out for a walk
and i know that some people also wrote
we have never in the city by the way
band walking
or bicycling in fact the opposite i
encourage you get out there
keep your space wear a mask but go for a
walk go for a bike ride
make sure you do those things that can
help you get through this tough time
don't just stay indoors and make sure
that if you do have
any mental health issues that you reach
out and you tell people about them
so that we can all get through this
together and if you know someone who is
suffering check in on them
call them facetime them make sure
they're okay and not isolated
so that this isolation does not compound
the mental health issues
that we have as we're taking individual
action we're also taking
steps to strengthen our public health
systems and so i want to make a couple
announcements tonight about that
last month we launched the covid
response innovations study
which is a pilot program on rapid
testing
it's bringing rapid testing directly to
angelinos to tap into our spirit of
ingenuity
and innovation and to give us as many
tools as possible
to hit the curve down quickly in phase
one of this study you might remember
we started with our firefighters and
essential workers who are on the front
lines and most vulnerable
and through that work we learned
important lessons about the accuracy of
the different tests that are out there
and how we can use them to quickly
identify where we're seeing spread
or outbreak and tonight i can share that
last week we launched
phase two evaluating the use of these
rapid tests
in the city's san fernando valley
supersite this phase is specifically
looking at people
without symptoms with a specific focus
on children between the ages of 5
and 18. we hope this will inform our
schools
form our educators and inform our young
people to see how these tests can help
us
in the future make sure they can learn
it'll open the door to a range of
possibilities
helping us stop transmissions earlier
making life safer for everyone from
students
to first responders and if they prove
effective with asymptomatic children
they could prove a critical resource for
helping open and reopen
schools safely i want to thank our
partners
in this study including usc curative our
testing partner
the rockefeller foundation and the la
county department of public health
and the federal department of health and
human services
as our understanding of this virus
continues to grow
so does our approach to fighting and
that's
true and new approaches to testing but
it's also true in our strategy around
contact tracing and i want to make an
announcement about that tonight
starting this week we are joining with
the county in a new digital contact
tracing program
introduced by our healthcare partner
health vanna this new initiative
sends patients their test results as
soon as they're processed
by our lab and if you test positive what
health fauna
now will give you the option of doing is
entering the names and the numbers
of people you recently came into contact
with so they can instantly
and anonymously get a text message
letting them know that you that they may
have been exposed to covet 19
and linking them with resources to
immediately get a free test
in the coming weeks we're going to make
it possible for them to also get a free
test by mail
so they don't even have to leave their
house in order to see
what their status is and remember as
always
when you get a call from a contact
tracer in the county
please answer it please finish their
questionnaire
this is the way that we will make sure
that we can quickly control
who has covert 19 and where it's
spreading
as we've seen from the start of this
this pandemic doesn't just threaten
lives
it threatens livelihoods so as we stay
focused on measures to protect lives and
the public health
we keep seeking ways to help our workers
our businesses
our renters families hit with
devastating force by the economic blow
of this crisis
and we didn't need another reminder of
how bad things were but today we got
that notice
when we got the latest jobs report
showing slowing growth and employment
hundreds of thousands of people leaving
the labor force altogether
and permanent layoffs on the rise
this affects people across our country
and the talks around a new federal
stimulus
have to get closed down we need a
package now i can't say it more clearly
to our leaders please don't go home for
the holidays
before you take care of the american
people i'm heartened to see those
conversations going
i'm heartened to hear the optimism
speaker pelosi
mentioned as well the way that we've
heard from the current administration
and the incoming administration the
importance of getting something done
and there has to be aid in there for our
schools
for our renters for our public transit
systems and for our state and local
governments
on the front lines there are glimmers of
hope that something will finally get
done in congress but we've never had the
luxury here
in l.a of waiting for a cavalry to come
and that's why this week
we announced the serve initiative a new
initiative that allows the delivery of
one-time 800
stipends to thousands of restaurant
workers who have faced the new
closures of outdoor dining and many of
them have lost hours and jobs
i want to remind everybody about this
again because the opening to apply for
this starts on monday at nine o'clock
it'll be open
all of the five work days of next week
so monday through friday and it doesn't
matter whether you're first
or the last person on friday it doesn't
affect how quickly you'll get
a check or whether you'll be picked
it'll be done fairly and randomly
you can go to coronavirus.lacity.org
serve if you don't have access to the
internet you can also call
311 and we can walk you through it
but even as we deploy these tools to try
to save lives to protect
livelihoods to help families pay the
most basic bills
the pandemic still remains on a very
very harmful path
we announced earlier what the infections
were
8 and sixty of them here in the city of
los angeles though
it was our highest number ever as well
three thousand seven hundred and fifty
six
if we stay on this case trajectory la is
projected to reach
half a million cases by the year's end
it's one out of 20 people here
if things don't change by year's end the
lives lost
will surpass 11 000 deaths
that means 3 000 additional deaths
in a single month to put that in
perspective it's a decade
of homicides it is more deaths than we
ever could expect in excess
of normal causes of death before this
pandemic
this is the greatest threat to life in
los angeles that we have ever faced
and the current levels of infection
won't just mean covet deaths
it means overwhelmed hospitals so that
people who have other life-threatening
health conditions might not get in or
will be competing for those very same
beds
that covid19 patients need people with
strokes
and heart attacks and other emergencies
unable to get care
that's why the state is using that
metric
i know it can sound confusing everything
isn't always consistent
but by looking at icu beds the state is
saying
when we're out of those beds we're going
to be in real trouble
and so the triggers come as those beds
fill up
and remember how this virus spreads the
cdc
defines exposure as contact within six
feet of someone
for 15 minutes or more there's just too
much
of that happening in los angeles in fact
the cdc
said if you're in a crowded household
today you should consider even wearing
masks
at home this is just the cdc advice
but we know how to control this please
do everything you can
to control it our transmission rate
remains at 1.14
well above one meaning that everybody
who's infected is infecting more than
one more person
which is why cases continue to rise we
need to get that number
down below one and right now
two thousand seven hundred and sixty
nine people are hospitalized
because of covert 19 a four percent
increase since yesterday
in three weeks our hospitalizations have
tripled
in the last week alone we saw a 42
percent
increase and as i mentioned before in
the previous briefing at this rate will
be out
of beds in two to four weeks we have 644
patients from covert 19 in the icu who
are severely sick
and who are hanging on right now this is
a major increase since
last month and each day we're seeing
these numbers increase
and while our local numbers remain
critically important
the state's orders aren't remember
triggered just by beds in l.a we're now
tied to a region
where we're facing massive shortages in
some of our neighboring counties
where they have not only no beds
available
but also no staff available as well
covered cases among health care workers
are up
71 remember when we used to ring the
cowbells
stop by the hospitals to thank the
workers
yell out of our windows and applaud
our healthcare workers need us and i
want them to know
and our lab technicians who are in
basements
turning out our tests people are coming
in to clean our hospitals
to feed our patients our doctors
our lab techs everybody that we see you
we see you we know who you are and we
thank you
but let's also bring down kovid for them
so that if we or somebody we love lands
in a hospital
they're there to help the county
reported today 60 new deaths
we mourn each and every one of those
lives with a name
and a story and a family and a community
that they leave behind
and we sadly expect this number to
continue to rise
but massive deaths are not a foregone
conclusion
it's in our hands one critical tool
in slowing those deaths is knowing your
covid19 status
as of this week we have now tested more
than 2.56
million tests at city sites far
north then far north of half of our
city's population
since the start of this pandemic and our
current positivity rate remember when it
was down to
three and four is now at 14.85 percent
in those testing centers
i committed to you just over a month ago
that we'd expand testing capacity
and we've done it and this coming week
we're going to do it again
we're seeing our tests fill up every
single day
and wait times but at the same time are
down
capacity is up and we have the quickest
turnaround times anywhere in the country
getting your test results back usually
within 24 hours
and by 36 hours today we can test nearly
40
000 people a day including the new sites
that we have at san fernando park
which is a walk-up site lax and
additional mobile units
tomorrow mobile teams will be in the
following locations
avalon boulevard and 103rd the north
hollywood
metro station baskin robbins on west
lawson avenue
la christian center in el soreno and
cesar chavez and soto in boyle heights
if you want to know where any of those
mobile testing sites are the static ones
any of the other places you can get
tested more than a hundred places
go to coronavirus.lacity.org
testing or call us at 311.
if you think you've been exposed get a
test immediately and remember
quarantine until you've received a
negative result
remember that that test result only
captures that day
the moment you took the test if it comes
back positive
remember that you have to isolate for 10
days
from the time your symptoms first
appeared and stay isolated for at least
24 hours after your last fever
the people that you've come into contact
need to quarantine and then get a test
at the end of their quarantine
all of these protocols are available at
publichealth.lacounty.gov
amid the constant stream of news all the
numbers that come out at us
it can be too easy to forget what all
this is for why
we care about those statistics why we
are making these painful sacrifices
all of it is to preserve human life
the threat of covet 19 is real it's
never been more dangerous
and the consequences are devastating
here in our city family the people that
provide the services for this city
the folks who are out there whether
they're librarians or firefighters
people that work doing the most basic
services
that help our city function we're
feeling that aching emptiness
as we mourn one of our own beloved
members
a father a partner a peacemaker
guided by his own early experiences in
gangs
and violence ever devoted his days
to making our city a city of angels and
a place of peace
it was his mission to show young people
across the city the power of faith
of hope and of love in the face of
violence
and poverty through his organization
the resilience agency ever had a team
of violence interrupters and everybody
who's doing that work out there
right now in the face of what we see
nationwide with new violence and
homicides
thank you for having that courage to
step between
the conflict to save the lives to be
angels
and nevada was certainly one of them
he was somebody who mobilized people
around him to build healthier
communities
he connected youth with new
opportunities to education into jobs
for so many who were blessed to know him
he was so much more than a leader
he was a friend who saw the good who saw
the possibility in
everyone who never gave up on anybody he
met
he was a partner and a guide on the walk
to a better life
one of his friends put it best
he didn't care where you came from all
he cared about
was if you needed him he was there for
you
lost he'd show you the way scared he'd
give you the courage
pained he would help you to heal that
was the mission
of his work the meaning of his life
andrea average partner in life love
and ministry to their seven children and
grandchildren our hearts
are so heavy with you tonight we mourn
alongside you
we cry with you and we'll work every day
to remember average incredible life to
honor his legacy
and to carry forward his life as we
traverse the difficult road
ahead let us call on the memory of ever
linares his compassion and his faith his
belief that we were all made in god's
image
and that we all have a mission to
fulfill here on
his earth so let's take care of each
other
lift up one another honor the sanctity
of our charge
and let's protect the people in the
communities that we love
l.a let's hunker down let's cancel our
plans
let's stay safe and stay healthy and
let's stay at home
love and strength for my family to yours
thank you
happy to take questions and as always
i'll speak in spanish after
thank you and our first question comes
from claudia ischuta knx news radio
hey claudia
how you holding up
this week people are already so
frustrated do you regret how that was
handled
my second question is given you can you
repeat that first one because
what do you think about the fact that
the la police prospective league won't
even meet with negotiators to talk about
possibly foregoing upcoming races for
officers thank you
sure claudia good to hear your voice you
cut off at the beginning will you tell
me
what the thing is that i'm uh you're
asking if i regret oh
sorry i'm having a hard time hearing you
with the second question you couldn't
the first one first one the first one
that you know that there was a lot of
confusion about the order
issues this week um if you regret how
that was handled the second question
um what do you think about the
protective league not not even meeting
with negotiators
talk about possibly foregoing upcoming
raises sure thank you
so if you're talking about the city's
order the city order just copies what
the county order
is um uh i know it'll shock people but i
think there was just a mistake
made by a reporter who said that we were
banning walking and biking we
never said that we never did we never
would um so no i don't regret it we
always try to align exactly with the
county's um
words we've done that except in a couple
rare cases throughout this entire
pandemic
so we want to make sure there is
uniformity that it says the same thing
and no i think that was just something
that got misreported and then part of an
echo chamber of people saying la is
banning walking which we never did never
would never will
in terms of uh the police protective
league they and all
unions um we have talked to and are
talking to and hope to continue talking
to so
i know there's been letters put out and
people saying look elsewhere
i'll reiterate the kind of values that i
bring forward first of all
this is not the fault of our city
employees in 2009 i think people could
make more reasonable
uh case that raises maybe were too big
city leaders had given two big raises
unions had gotten too big
raises when we saw the great recession
this is not the fault of city workers i
want them to hear that loud and clear
but second we will have to share we're
mostly
a business an entity an enterprise that
pays people to do things
we don't spend a lot on equipment or on
vehicles or things like that
most of our costs come from our own
salaries and so
we have to figure out a way to get
through this but i promise folks it'll
be shared
i also said that civilian and sworn
that's what we call
you know folks who have a badge police
and fire and then those who aren't
uh will both be a part of those
discussions and that i will make
layoffs the very last option that we
have
we have to sometimes think ahead and
plan ahead and it causes everybody to
feel
terrible worried we'll have a job i was
just the newest one hired by seniority
i'm going to be gone it is my promise to
my people
in this city family that we will do
everything we can
to get the federal assistance that we
deserve to look at every other way
forward but yes we will continue talking
to folks
and just as we did in 2009 to get
through things we'll figure this out
together and i have that confidence with
our
police protective league i have that
confidence with our firefighters i have
that confidence with our
non-sworn employees that are part of the
coalition our uh
engineers and architects association in
every single union and we will lead as i
said
uh the last briefing by example starting
with ourselves
of any sacrifices that we have to make
and it is my hope though
then the next two weeks we can have at
least a sliver of some good news coming
from washington
that can avert those layoffs and they
can deal with other ways that we can
close the budget
thanks claudia next question please
thank you and that comes from albert
cerna a journalist at san francisco
university
hey good evening mayor thank you for
taking the time to talk to us
um i wanted to ask uh three questions
first and foremost um regarding the
serve initiative
are there screening uh measures in place
to ensure that the most vulnerable
receive relief
first or is it going to be essentially
everybody's going to be in the lottery
and then i wanted to ask if there was a
plan for rent forgiveness for those
unable to pay back rent when the
moratorium ends in january
and then finally i wanted to know um if
and how your office has worked with the
department of probation and department
of public health
to ensure the safety of youth in
juvenile detention facilities
thank you sure the last one isn't under
our jurisdiction
we do work all the time of making sure
that we have diversion program very
proud that in
some divisions we've been able to divert
as much as 85 percent of what used to be
juvenile arrests but
both of those are squarely under the
county so not under our jurisdiction
um for rent forgiveness obviously the
city can't forgive the rent um but it is
something that i'm in favor of
to be able to have federal legislation
and state
state and federal assistance to
essentially what some people call cancel
rent or council mortgages
but to help our mom and pop owners
and renters to be able to figure out a
way to either pay off over time
or even have forgiveness of some of
their
rent as long as it doesn't come at the
expense of
you know mom and pop landlords losing uh
their uh
investment losing in many cases their
only livelihood and it becoming
corporatized
today with the mayor of miami
francis suarez we did a kind of
announcement there's a cnn op-ed that we
wrote
to building on what we're seeing in
other cities a program to look at
people's rental deposits as well 45
billion dollars
which is sit there in escrow accounts
that
can be tapped should be able to be
tapped to help renters and landlords to
be able to
pay for another month of rent and in
some cities and we're exploring that
here
we're able to then uh mandate that folks
can get insurance that make sure no
landlord would ever lose
that uh deposit but in the meantime that
that could be put to work
paying for rent today and so we're going
to be exploring that here in los angeles
as a way
to help with that rent as well as two
other programs
obviously the 103 million dollars that
is rolling out as we speak
millions of dollars each day in direct
rental assistance
and then the utility assistance program
that we have to through our department
of water and power
finally the serv program which is yet
another one of our cash assistance
programs
uh that is already for the most
vulnerable it's for folks that have
lost hours or jobs it's under a given
income
level and as long as you qualify it will
be done
for that vulnerable group uh with random
fair
way similar to what we did with angelino
card similar to what we've done with
other programs
i will say this for those who would want
to go even deeper into trying to figure
out stuff you can't get money out
quickly
if you go too deep there isn't the
capacity we've seen systems overwhelm
and break down
but we are confident this is the
vulnerable these are vulnerable
employees
from the restaurant industry who are
hard hit by the closures
and they will be able to get um this
assistance 800 each
thank you i'm told that is the final
question appreciate the questions and
thank you albert and claudia as well
i'll turn now to spanish um
thank you to everybody who's tuning out
from the english side um
for being with us this evening and thank
you again for taking to heart just how
strong these numbers are
and how dangerous kovit is right now
please have a good weekend
stay safe and stay healthy
california
[Music]
a a sympomaticos
estas pruebas pueden ayudarnos
escuelas ademas empezando estas amana
juntos con el condado
is
a
d
[Music]
[Music]
pacifica
[Music]
good night
[Music]
[Music]
you